as if we needed to up the stakes in
today's election
as if the country's future wasn't
already riding on this election
we have another wrinkle new report by
the new york times
as well as by best levin in vanity fair
reveals that donald trump
is not just looking to win because he's
a narcissistic egomaniac
he's also reportedly terrified about
going to prison
if he loses today's election this is not
just based on existing investigations
but on potential new ones he expects
quote from the new york times article
seldom far from trump's thoughts is the
possibility of defeat
and the potential consequences of being
ejected from the white house
in unguarded moments trump has for weeks
told advisers
he expects to face intensifying scrutiny
from prosecutors if he loses
he is concerned not only about existing
investigations in new york
but the potential for new federal probes
as well according to people who have
spoken with them
the new yorker's jane mayer has similar
reporting she writes quote trump's legal
expenses alone are likely to be daunting
by the time bill clinton left the white
house he'd racked up more than 10
million in legal fees
and trump's finances are already under
growing strain during the next four
years according to a stunning recent
times report
trump whether reelected or not must meet
payment deadlines for more than 300
million dollars in loans
that he is personally guaranteed much of
his debt is owed
to such foreign creditors as deutsche
bank
unless he can refinance with the lenders
he will be on the hook
cornered animals become desperate donald
trump is very cornered right now
one of the reasons he's desperate to win
is the concern about being prosecuted
now also fascinatingly from the new york
times piece
donald trump has people around him
telling him he's definitely going to win
tonight listen to this
quote the president his associates say
has drawn encouragement from his larger
audiences
and from a stream of relatively upbeat
polling information
that advisors have curated forum
typically filtering out the bleakest
numbers
on a trip to florida last week several
aides told the president that winning
the electoral college
was a certainty a prognosis not
supported
by republican or democratic polling mark
meadows
chief of staff has responded with
chipper enthusiasm
when trump raised the idea of making a
late bid
for solidly democratic states like new
mexi
new mexico an option other aides have
told the president
is flatly unrealistic this is important
because when trump says he's winning
everything at his rallies
if people around trump are actually
telling him you've got this
you've got the electoral college if he
doesn't win it
he will definitely think it was rigged
if you're thinking
i'm down seven but maybe i can pull this
off
if you don't win you sort of are
expecting it if everybody around you is
saying
you're going to win the electoral
college and you don't
you react very differently and you
probably do all the things we're worried
donald trump
is going to do now fortunately or
unfortunately for trump versus for the
country
the country does not have a history of
prosecuting past presidents
that suggests trump doesn't need to
worry but
past presidents also haven't had this
level of corruption
in their past so it could change if
everything that
should be investigated is investigated
whenever the time comes
the trump family would likely be tied up
in court for
a long time to be perfectly frank
probably through the rest of donald
trump's life
trump being prosecuted would be a
tremendously lovely ending
but trump out of office is the goal
right now
we have the opportunity to do it today
and i hope you'll join me tonight i will
be streaming live starting at 7 pm
eastern 4 p.m pacific as the results
start coming in
on youtube twitch
and facebook do not miss it one of our
sponsors today
is vincero watches and they're giving
you 15
off everything in the store if you're a
guy looking for the perfect way
to refresh your style one of the best
investments you can make
is in a high quality wrist watch vincero
is an american company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about two
hundred dollars but it'll look like you
spent a lot more
all of their watches are made in small
batches from top quality materials and
they just look great
i went on their site and picked out a
watch from their icon
automatic collection the one i got is in
mesh matte black
and i love it it's simple sleek elegant
goes great with just about
anything i'm wearing and i've gotten a
ton of compliments on it
you'll get 15 off everything in their
store when you go to davidpakman.com
watch and i've put that link right
underneath this video